and on the mount for the new york mets
as we mentioned the 34 year old
right-hander carlos carrasco this is his
first start of the year got off to a
slow start overcoming a series of
physical problems turner trying to get
the dodgers on the scoreboard first
tonight and turner hits a high drive to
left center field this ball's back this
ball is gone a home run justin turner
instant offense in new york and the
dodgers lead it two nothing turner with
his 21st home run of the year he returns
to new york
returns to the starting lineup
and hits a
396-foot bomb to left-center here's will
smith now
smith the summer twice in the series did
he just add another
smith on the look for that one and yes
homer's throughout this series for will
smith
three-nothing los angeles
will smith already the hero friday night
also on saturday night
and tonight third day in a row with a
home run on the fastball
three-nothing lead for max scherzer so
stake to an advantage before he goes to
work nine and four overall this year now
for jeff mcneal first and third two gone
two and two to jeff mcneil
in the air out to shallow left
taylor finds it
and retires the side so now trey turner
who's singled and scored in front of the
justin turner homer last inning
into left field and that's going to
drive in bellinger to make it
four-nothing dodgers turner on his way
to second turn is just a prime time
player turner at second base max muncie
second time up max is all for one and
the payoff is hit high in the air to
slight left center it is deep it is back
it is gone
a home run for max muncie
and the dodgers had two more it is six
to nothing
home run number 24
for max
419
feet jd davis leads things off against
max scherzer 2-2 pitch swag on a missed
strike three pumped the fastball past
him at 94.
and there's one out in the mets half of
the second credit carrasco with the sack
but second and third with two gone
rolled out to second base for turner and
once again two are left stranded in the
mets half of an inning now the mets are
set up second and third with no outs
and smith pops it again this one handled
by turner one away
metz are now two for 22 with runners in
scoring position in the series another
opportunity for jeff mcneal
[Applause]
metzer on the scoreboard on the rbi
ground ball up to bed to jeff mcneil
it's a six to one dodger lead all in two
strikes
got him back to back elevated fastballs
do the trick no further damage in the
new york half of the third billy
mckinney leading off the fourth 1-1 is
ripped to the right side alonso with a
diving catch nice play by pete
mckinney hit it hard to the right side
alonso laid out for it with a dive to
his right a sprawling grab by alonso and
there's one out here in the fourth the
defensive play of the game and a board
with two away from max muncie there you
go
to the same spot the ballpark
but this one is run down by brandon
nimmo to retire the side
corners will crash in on jake green
making his first career plate appearance
at the major league level tonight
he puts into play
throw this first is too late into third
and that's too late wow the mets got out
of that one somehow
vr avoided the tag at second and then by
the time the dodgers tried to get the
hitter that was too late reed runs well
again it's conforto with a chance
their best track record here against
scherzer by far and conforto puts it in
play to first muncie will get the out
there they concede the run do the
dodgers it's a six to two la lead
second and third with the running and
two gone now
the next one two pitch
oh he got him looking
bottom of the zone breaking ball enough
to get him out of another jam the best
stranded two in the first two in the
second one in the third two more in the
fourth
and he makes quick work of dom smith
here's jeff mcneil
who talked about mcneal being a first
pitch guy had a first pitch pop
for seager to make the catch i think
they'd agree everybody would agree it
worked out
his first 1-2-3 ending the ball game a
couple of strikeouts to boot we've
played five complete at city field
tonight the dodgers continue to lead one
out to runner at third max scherzer
looking for an rbi he doesn't have one
this year the max swings and hits a ball
to right center field plenty deep enough
it is caught by nimmo tagging from third
and scoring is mckinney and the first
rbi of the season for max scherzer gives
the dodgers another run it is 7-2 here's
max muncie now
[Applause]
muncie out to the left center field
again same spot same result
second two-run digger of the night for
max muncie
and for muncie
waiting back at the chain jump
almost to the exact same spot 106 off
the bat
two balls and two strikes to count to
jonathan vr
swing and a miss and vr out on strikes
that's six strikeouts now for scherzer
as he has settled in
0-2 pitch is hit in the air to right
field a few steps to his glove side is
mckinney
and he makes the catch putting it away
for out number two
as blankenhorn strikes out back to back
one two three innings for max scherzer
dick pete alonso can lean into one here
we have something to talk about runners
aboard but nobody out here in the
seventh delivers and this ball is popped
up to center field bellinger gets
underneath it he'll make the catch and
the runners cannot advance not hit deep
enough nimo conforto and smith the board
with one
mcneil that one misses him and it
bounces away
it's a wild pitch that brings nemo in to
score
one swing of the back to make it a two
run game
there's a swing and a drive out to
center field bellinger at the wall to
put it away
conforto will tag up and score and man
did jd davis come close to that very
two
three got scenario
metal settled with two in their half of
the seventh rodgers with a chance to do
some two out damage and will smith
coming up 2-2 there's a shot to left
center field and a base hit user comes
in to score here comes muncie around
third he'll score
and will smith knocks in two it's 11 for
dodgers
get those two runs back now taylor hits
it to left field it's rolling toward the
corner seeger will score with an end to
second with a two out rbi double is
chris taylor taylor now one for five
richard that's did it reappear it again
this afternoon matt beatty swings and
drives one deep to right field it is in
the upper deck and gone a two run home
run for matt beatty
[Applause]
14-4
the mets are down to their last out
swing and a miss
strike three mcneal is out ball game
over
and the dodgers sweep the mets in new
york